i am a freestyle rapper that means i
make up raps on the spot based on your
suggestions and i know you're all too
polite to say this but don't worry i did
not expect me to look like this either
um based on whatever you want but to do
that you need to give me suggestions so
what i want you guys to do
think of a word a topic or a phrase that
you would like to hear a rap about there
are some rules
okay to make it as good and as
challenging as possible number one
don't suggest food it's the most common
thing our brains think of number two
don't suggest animals too obvious number
three
don't be too obvious in general okay you
can really push the bow out you can
challenge me
some of the best suggestions i ever had
include 9th century crop rotation
afghani irrigation ditches and i had a
german man in hamburg say
a day in the life of an aztec high
priest
[Music]
aim for those kind of esoteric creative
suggestions now if you have a suggestion
all you got to do
do a little wave in front of your camera
i'll get you on spotlight
we'll take your suggestions i can see
there we have brian
hi brian my gosh that's the most
terrifying thing i've ever seen
are you in the back of someone's
chevrolet what's happening
somewhere yeah i think so okay
well you know just count the bumps in
the road and figure out what
municipality you're in
brian what would you like a rap about
turtles
that's an animal unfortunately brian so
what you can do is
you can expand on it you can give it an
activity or an adjective which is a
describing word what would you like
us to you know focus on with the turtles
turtle uh i'm going to getting donuts
a turtle get it so an animal getting
food okay fine
turtle getting donuts so much brian
tell you what mate i'm glad they've put
you in the trunk of their car
i hope they go all the way i hope you
upset the mob um
so susie is waving let's get susie on
here
hey susie and randy i don't know which
one's you i i don't want to assume which
of you is more randy than the other
what would you like a rap about uh dr
seuss
dr seuss brilliant stuff very topical
very topical
um my my mother wouldn't let me read dr
zeus growing up because she said
um it was american and therefore it
would lead me down a bad path
turns out she's been proved right so
well done mum
well done mum thank you very much lovely
people there
let's get our third suggestion give me a
wave if you've got it
bernard bernard is is waving hey bernard
is it bernard or bernard how posh are
you yes it's bernardo bernard
bernado bernard great a yellow
highlighter
a yellow highlighter brilliant thank you
very much i love
you could have suggested anything in the
world you could have said niagara falls
you could have said the emu war you went
no this is by me i'll pick this up and
use this
great suggestions oh
okay well we'll save them for next time
thank you so much bernard bernard
two more suggestions coming who are they
from
i can see the uh angel or ang hell it's
hard to know how to pronounce are you
angel or angel
it's angel hey an angel hi
uh lava lamp lava lamps brilliant did
you have one in your bedroom growing up
i i have one in my bedroom oh my gosh
living the dream you've still got it
that's amazing
well lava lamps from angel thank you so
much
let's get our final suggestion um one
final one
this it doesn't have to be the best one
it has to be the last one i can see
there we've got alex
hey alex what would you like a rap about
north korean defectors north korean
defectors
amazing stuff thank you very much that
is the smile if someone has gone yeah
deal with that you idiot portray a rap
about north korean defectors
cheers alex um amazing great
those are the suggestions to remind you
a turtle getting donuts
doctor's use a yellow highlighter lava
lamps and north korean defectors this is
a freestyle that's a wrap made up on the
spot based in town
no suggestions and do not worry it will
not be anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly toe curly bad
as you'd expect to probably educate a
middle class white boy to be
let's drop that beat let's get this
going ah
time to get funky
[Music]
when it comes to psychedelic i'm the
champ i got a lava lamp i put it on my
bedside table
ever since i was 21 i was able to
purchase my own
decorator home i felt royal like a king
on the throne
what is that fluid what does it do
moving around like mercurial goo
act like a temperature in thermometer
like mercury i got one on there
by the side of my bed yeah never fear
i'm in the grateful dead jerry garcia
cause i like to get
so trippy when i see a lava lamp i'm
like hippies
must be nearby if they got plenty let me
travel back in time to the 70s
oh what's here can you deduce i want to
read this book by dr seuss
but now 2021 people say this throw it
away
this book is racist really let me look
inside
green eggs and ham that's not that snide
but this one
oh him again he says yeah i don't like
the mexicans
whoa doctor you need to calm that down
go back there to your american town
wherever you're from i know it's not
your real name
rhyme it fox's socks again and again
he's a rapper from back in the day
as offensive as one contemporary let me
go along like i pull an all-nighter pick
it out like a yellow highlighter yeah
you can't get better but the one that
bernard had wasn't a stetler
knock off brand so the ink leaked out in
your hand if you try and pick the words
out
when i had an essay in college i would
pick up the little stationery and
acknowledge that the yellow was the best
color better than the rest
orange nah that's a real pest talk about
this
you instruct in the trunk of the cart
doughnuts
got by a little turtle off to the donut
store they hurt or running so fast
you know it's kind of painful if they're
diabetic so they give them to april
that's the report cause the turtles i
said were the ninja ones the straps
round their head
oh down there in the manhole sewer a
donut hole
they are a pursuer of all of the
sprinkles you know they're keen share it
with the team you got krispy kreme they
get a dozen
that's three each if you count just the
turtles but
you didn't amount to anything like
master splinter shredded coming in like
a little printer cause it's slow
last one i try and deflect this if i'm
in north korea defection
is my one true aim out of order kim
jong-un's like close down the border
north koreans come worship me why you're
trying to run across the dmz
so he tells those soldiers squat down
get the defectors shot them down and he
does
frequently because he's just a horrible
man there you go
thank you very much for that guys look
at those suggestions i i was fortunate
enough to attend a human rights
conference in oslo norway in 2017
and i did meet a north korean defector
um and
uh it was a very sad story and i was
thinking about that the whole time i was
doing the rap just like oh yeah her
whole family was murdered once she left
so
good to laugh about that isn't it what
i'm gonna do to to
to end is we could do another wrap but
this is actually kind of
bernard you you kind of figured this one
out because what i want to do is i want
to get all of you involved so if you
haven't got your camera on
put it on you can get involved with this
one because you don't need to give me a
word all you need to do is hold up a
thing
now bernard went the prosaic route he
held up a highlighter
yeah you can do that or you've got 20
seconds to go and get the weirdest thing
in your house
bring that back here hold it up i bet i
can rap about it
that's a challenge go find something
that i can't rap about hold up in front
of the camera
alex i'm gonna give you the um the
ability
you can what i want you to do alex is
when i drop this beat
i would like you to just do the replace
spotlight
so everyone like the whole screen is
taken up with a spotlight
of random people just pick them out as
long as they've got the camera on
they're holding something up
i'll rap about it is that all good for
you
yeah great okay i'm gonna cue up a beat
you got 10 more seconds to get your
things guys hold them nice and close to
the screen
let's get this beat going alex i'll tell
you when to spot like that first person
and we're getting it funkier we're
getting it faster with this one
okay and in about five seconds alex
spotlight that first person for me
and uh we'll see how we do let's get it
going who's number one going to be
and then just rotate every 12 seconds
start off like 3 4 when i'm running down
juggling
like three balls clutch on the side with
the yellow and the red got the beans
inside and you know they were bred on
the farm
sticking them together maybe got the
fabric never use the leather
oh if i want to include a gong in the
song go to bed and sing
bowl hope i never use it wrong gotta get
the felt there on the handle move it
around the rim but the correct
angle otherwise bret you forget the tone
got like 60 hertz on my own
when i'm in t-bet you know what i like
no talk talk but a motorbike i hop in
that back and i say let's go
can a red bull made by lego did you know
they're the biggest manufacturer of
tires that's a fact for you
i don't lie don't leave me in the lurch
it's just a dark room there by nicole
church
but here we go it's a ghostly hand
coming in from the side with bananagrams
i'm gonna mix it round
yeah it's cute i like to play that game
with the names of the fruit yo
julie stein house on one got a whole
pack of the condoms
yes get it down so the sperm are broken
can't get in can't penetrate with the
trojan
are you a very large dude coming in
extra large and no lube
look at this yo it's a real party wave
at the side and we got a little barbie
mermaid tails like she's under the water
presumably it's owned by your daughter i
ain't got one got a gi joe
look at these testicles they hang low
two little balls
looking like a bowler i didn't say ebola
so you know that i'm not trying
to offend anyone got their little yellow
spheres and they're moving on side to
side
unlike lance armstrong only got one ball
don't get this wrong look at that rope
running through like a tiny little
puzzle
oh lake farming putting you in a model
what a great name
you always be through are you swedish
that's the name and id
juice oh i'm in luck it's like mexican
but donald duck he'll be going down
there down low
rocking out with that sombrero how did
he get here
how's he here at all i thought donald
duck can't fly over the wall he just
walks in
no pants on the bottom sam toning went
to italy and cottoned
you can get a little mocha pot espresso
on that put it on the stove keep it very
hot then the pressure forms up oh why
get a nice coffee drink psi pressure per
square inch and if i want to be so cool
look at this you be showing off the cube
can you do it quicker did you rearrange
the sticker
i don't even know yet you could even
pick a tiny cube by rubix it's on by him
ivan decca yeah give me that white print
put it with a hip-hop triceratops
look at that wall art that you got and a
nice suit with a little horn
waking up hard early in the morn
dinosaur
feeling very clever skin's so tough but
it ain't got feathers
look at this this is great from back in
the day do you remember when we had the
second wave
it was so cool it was just a joke you're
like i wanna have a hand that's made of
foam it says stay away man
like my name's bar rock on like kiss
with the art on stage
rocking what can we see kathy harold
black is that your name properly
looking like a sculptor looking like
some art bring it much closer
where thou art have you got some oars on
the wall looking like a tiny little
spoon i might fall
always struggling when i'm trying to
figure out get my fill let me put the
hole in it like i'm handling the drill
don't need a cord cause you got the
battery looking like a bitten foil
burrito e
wrap it round the side you can handle
aluminum
yeah understandable oh i love to share
you don't need a bottle opener for
gibson's rare
12 years old coming with the scotch
knock it back down
drinking it a lot last thing that we do
yeah i'm a good luck that's the final
little thing we did there for cindy
tucker boom
i'm sorry sorry mark beddard but quite
appropriately
that is the white boy out guys
i hope you've enjoyed your night out
ending with the white out uh
if you oink like a pig that's a right
snout that's me chris turner thank you
so much guys pleasure wrapping for you
all the best